[Musique]
nous sommes heureux de pouvoir vous
parler de d'une exposition très
intéressante qui se déroule à l'heure
actuelle à l'espace Richaud à Versailles
qui concerne deux grands photographes de
un français et un Roumain tous les deux
sont nés dans les années 1000
1894 et ils sont décédés donc en 60 en
86 1 à 85 et l'autre à 86 pour Jacques
Henri Lartigue Jacques Henri garrigue on
le connaît c'était c'est lui qui avait
fait la photo officielle du Giscard
d'Estaing que nous avons derrière
et kerese donc c'est un personnage
d'origine roumaine qui lui était plutôt
de conditions modeste contrairement à
Jacques Henri Lartigue qui était d'une
famille de grands bourgeois d'ailleurs
dans les photos que nous vous présentons
on verra que Jacques-Henri l'Artigue un
de ces quelqu'un de sa famille fabriqué
des des comment s'appelle des et il
s'est initié à essayer de s'envoler avec
des avions qui étaient tirés par des
hommes André cartel est venu en France
en 1936 entre les deux guerres et il a
vécu une période en France ils étaient
d'ailleurs amis très proches avec
Jacques-Henri lactique il y en a un qui
s'est initié au journaliste qui était
André kertez et
Jacques Henri Lartigue lui sur la photo
plus de monde la vie intime de sa
famille et il a montré quand même de
très très belles choses et des très
beaux portraits des gens de sa famille
cette exposition se déroule à l'espace
Richaud dans un cadre assez très
versaillé je dirais et il est
intéressant pour vous d'aller voir cette
exposition dans lequel vous pourrez voir
des tirages d'origine qui ont été prêtés
par la Fondation l'Artigue et aussi de
cartes S mais qui lui faisait des photos
beaucoup plus petites parce que il
n'avait pas les mêmes moyens que
Monsieur Lartigue les deux ont été
exposés au moment de New York à des
périodes c'est un peu différente parce
que c'était des gens qui étaient très
proches et qui se sont découverts bien
que leur niveau social était
complètement différent comme vous pouvez
voir sur cette image donc là nous avons
une image de Jacques Henri Lartigue qui
avait photographié et Sacha Guitry quand
on connaît Sacha Guipry qui était dans
l'excessif etc donc on voit bien comment
il l'avait habillé comme disait quartier
Bresson qu'a connu André kerese
photographié c'est voir ce que les
autres ne voient pas et aussi bien
Jacques-Henri Lartigue que André kertez
ont su dénoter dans leur photographie si
vous voulez
quelque chose de très particulier avant
de terminer je voudrais m'arrêter sur
une photo que j'ai prise donc lors de la
visite de cette exposition ou à partir
de la photo qui était exposée il y avait
un reflet qui rentrait dans la photo et
ça me permet de rajouter une note
personnelle à cette photo que je trouve
très intéressante puisque quand vous
regardez cette photo si vous voulez vous
voyez l'A
chaleureux que vous avez dans cette
maison et le fait de rajouter cette
glace si cette fenêtre si vous voulez
apporter une touche personnelle et
peut-être plus actuelle
[Musique]